ما افاد به مراسلنا قبل قليل بان 34 شهيدا
وصلوا منذ صباح اليوم الى مجمع الشفاء
الطبي في غزه وارتقى 11د ع اخرون متاثرين
بجراحهم كذلك افاد مراسل الجزيره بسقوط
جرحه اثر قصف اسرائيلي استهدف منزلا قرب
مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه
للمتابعه ينضم الينا من مستشفى الشهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح
مراسلنا هشام زقوت هشام حصيله جديده اذا
لعدد الشهداء والجرحى الذين يسقطون كل
ساعه تقريبا في هذه العمليات الاسرائيليه
والقصف الاسرائيليه المستمر على مواقع
متفرقه من شمال القطاع الى جنوبه ما طبيعه
المعلومات التي
وصلتكم هو هو استمرار للقصف الاسرائيلي
واستمرار لوصول الشهداء في مدينه غزه ووصل
الى مستشفى الشفاء اكثر من 30 شهيدا 40
شهيد في مستشفى الاقصى وصلوا من مناطق
مختلفه منذ فجر هذا اليوم من جراء استهداف
منازل ثلاثه منازل في مخيم النصيرات وايضا
منزلين في مخيم المغازي وكان هناك انتشال
لعدد من الشهداء في مخيم البريج وايضا
قصفت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه سياره
في شارع العشرين في مخيم النصيرات ونقل
الى هنا شهيد جراء هذا الاستهداف بالتالي
هي عمليات مستمره بالاضافه الى استمرار
القصف الاسرائيلي سواء في خانيونس سواء في
رفح وبالتالي كل محافظات قطاع غزه تتعرض
ما بين الفينه والاخرى الى قصف من قبل
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه فيما تواصل
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه قصف المناطق الشرقيه
لقطاع غزه بالقذائف في خانيونس جنوب قطاع
غزه استهدفت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
منزلا بالقرب من مستشفى ناصر ومستشفى ناصر
هو بات المجمع الاكبر بعد ان خرج مجمع الش
فاء الطبي عن ال الخدمه وبالتالي الاضرار
تصل الى هذا المجمع وكانت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه خلال على مدار الايام
تقصف منزل بالقرب من هذا المجمع ولكن كانت
تقصفه بصواريخ صوتيه وبالتالي كانت هناك
يعني ضغوط كبيره يتعرض لها الاطباء الذين
يتواجدون والطواقم الطبيه التي تتواجد في
هذا المستشفى من جراء هذه الاستهدافات
المتكرره لمحيط هذا المستشفى وايضا
للمنازل ايضا م جاوره له وبكل تاكيد القصف
المدفعي مازال مستمرا ومتواصلا ويصل صداه
الى هذا المستشفى كذلك القصف المدفعي في
منطقه بن سيلا والقرار وخزاعه وعبس وايضا
يصل الى مناطق وسط البلد في خان يونس جنوب
قطاع غزه بالاضافه الى القصف من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه ايضا في مناطق وسط
القطاع القصف مازال مستمرا ومتواصلا على
المناطق الشرقيه لمخيم المغازي وللمخرج
كذلك ا في تطور ورات مخيم البريج على وجه
التحديد ساسال ك لاحقا عن التطورات
المرافقه للمعارك هناك لكن اسمح لي هشام
وتابع معي هذه الارقام الجديده التي
تقدمها وزاره الصحه بغزه خلال هذه اللحظات
كما نقراها على شاشتنا اذا تقول وزاره
الصحه في غزه ان
187 شهيدا
و312 مصابا في القطاع خلال الساعات ال 24
الماضيه وفي حصيله اجم لعدد الشهداء
والجرحى منذ بدء هذه الحرب تتحدث وزاره
الصحه كما نتابع على شاشتنا عن ارتفاع عدد
ضحايا العدوان الاسرائيلي الى
2157 شهداء
و55
و915 مصابا هذه هي اذا احدث حصيله تقدمها
وزاره الصحه في غزه لعدد الشهداء
والمصابين منذ بدء هذه الحرب اذا
217 شهداء
و55
و915 مصابا هي اذا الحصيله هشام و كنت
تتحدث قبل قليل عما يجري وعن حصيله هذه
الساعات الاولى من هذا الجمعه لكن عن
تطورات المعارك البريه تحديدا ما يجري في
شمال مخيم البريج هذا المخيم المحاصر
المقطوع والمعزول
تحيطه هذه المعارك ما الذي بلغكم عما يجري
هناك
هشام بالفعل هي معارك ضاريه مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لا سما وان الجيش الاسرائيلي
تقدم لعده كيلومترات في داخل مخيم البريج
بالاضافه الى توغل الدبابات الاسرائيليه
في المناطق الشماليه لهذا المخيم من منطقه
جحر الديك وبالتالي بات مخيم البريج
محاصرا من عدد من الجهات بالاضافه الى
محاصرته من جراء اطلاق الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه صواريخ على مداخل هذا المخيم
وبالتالي قصفت وتضررت هذه المداخل قصفت
وتضررت ولم تستطع سيارات الاسعاف وسيارات
الدفاع المدني في كثير من الايام الدخول
الى هذا المخيم الدبابات الاسرائيليه
توغلت من الجهه الشرقيه بالاضافه الى
التوغل المستمر من الجهه الشماليه من جهه
جحر الديك وهذه الدبابات تمركزت في عده
مناطق هناك و على اطراف هذا المخيم هناك
اشتباكات ضاريه المقاومه الفلسطينيه تعلن
ما بين الفينه والاخرى عن اطلاقها قذائف
وتفجيرها عبوات ناسفه باتجاه هذه القوات
التي تحاول الدخول لكن على ما يبدو ان
المقاومه اعاقتها وما زالت هذه القوات
الاسرائيليه متواجده في الاطراف في
المناطق المفتوحه تقصف بعنف المناطق في
قلب مخيم البريج وبالتالي هناك عدد من
الشهداء والجرحى ما زالوا على الارض لم
تستطع سيارات الاسعاف وسيارات الدفاع
المدني الوصول اليهم بالتالي هي عمليات
اشتباكات مستمره لكن حتى الوصول ل
المعلومه في مخيم البريج بات صعبا للغايه
بسبب حاله النزوح الكبيره من هناك وايضا
بسبب استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي وبالتالي
لا يستطيع احد الدخول ولا يستطيع احد اصلا
التحرك في هذا المخيم فهناك طائرات مسيره
تطلق النار على كل ما يتحرك الدبابات
الاسرائيليه تطلق تطلق القذائف باتجاه وسط
وقلب هذا المخيم وبات المخيم عباره عن
مدينه اشباح في ظل استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي على هذه المناطق واستمرار ايضا
الاشتباكات مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه شرا
جزيلا لك حتى الان هشام زقو كنت معنا من
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح